allez venez monde alessandra moi je fais
tout ce que vous voulez alessandra je
sais même pas ce qu'on va faire c'est
vraiment vous arrivez sur des beats on
dirait aujourd'hui on va commencer par
une petite action collective d'accord et
dac
donc je vais appeler l'assistant comme
dans l'émission pour m'apporter le
premier objet de l'action collective
mais c'est d'y aller
j'aime bien cette action collective
s'adresse à vos chroniques un bel air où
la fille sont comme ça les secteurs
alimentation je les vends j'ai beaucoup
d'animateurs qui dans cette émission
était parfois sert d'un petit peu et
influent c'est simple vous allez avoir
chacun votre tour le choix de prendre un
oeuf et de le taper sur la tête d'un oui
il y en a des durs et des mous et ya des
durs j'adore
ils n'ont pas le droit de les toucher
alors nyse le tout ils le prennent
voilà c'est ça alors alessandra est ok
matthieu delormeau on va démarrer
parfois j'adore ce style c'est ce qui
fait que m du coup mais si la personne à
manara comme ça d'accord oui ça manquait
les inquiéter je paie nature je précède
il ya bien eu agression c'est pas la
peine alors alors on y va pas chez la
société de production chd oh oui la
mienne c'est max motion d'accord te
propose la maxe battle h2o d'accord ait
une bataille
tout simple comme quand on joue et quand
on était gamins à chaque fois que l'un
d'eux nous père il prend un verre d'eau
il prend un verre d'eau dans la gueule
d'un cas si on fait égalité
il a bataillé on prend celui-là c'est
exact ivement la petite car j'adore si
c'est lui qui a fini ses verres en
premier aura le droit de quoi à une méga
surprise pour l'autre à attendant je
regarde derrière des trois jeux they
kiss my own
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon j'ai compris
[Musique]
alors là pas trop forte baisse
[Applaudissements]
j'adore j'adore
attention
est-ce qu'on peut enlever la burqa voile
sur les cheveux longs ballons pour
isabelle bon dieu attention
elle lui a pété la tête à la pause et la
terre des bras
[Applaudissements]
j'aime bien ce jeu j'aimerais un gay
attention à 2,3
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
attention aux mondiaux
[Applaudissements]
magath ouais
si je gagne c'est derrière attention tu
prend cher en tout cas on se calme photo
tl il est pas bien je rappelle qu'elle
est en pleine arrivée un axe batteur h2o
attention l âme soeur a dit tu es prêt
moines à tuband doll eyes and as toi
j'étais calme et attend alors attend
maintenant un 2/3 aux punaises dans la
carte de merde
[Applaudissements]
sujet
bien
pour touba
c'est la partie
[Applaudissements]
ouf
oui
je